when scared or threatened mammals can  respond in different ways they can  freeze fight or run away now  scientists have been studying mice to  identify the brain regions involved in  this split-second decision they showed  the mice a looming overhead threat the  mice responded in the typical ways  either by freezing seeking shelter or  aggressively rattling their tails the  scientists monitored the mice is brain  activity during the experiment to find  the pathways involved in the different  responses they found that mice who had  been scared before were more likely to  respond aggressively this reinforcement  of aggressive behavior is a survival  mechanism but it could malfunction in  humans exploring this mechanism could  help researchers understand conditions  like PTSD and phobias  [Music]